i've seen so many uh testimonials and
tributes to john madden
um and i saw many from uh from this man
as well and i said you know what let's
get some of them on this show right here
um and i've known him forever and a day
we were at espn together as well
uh he is in the midst right now of let
me get this correct his 32nd season is
the lead producer for an nfl primetime
game and his 16th season producing
sunday night football for nbc he is
executive producer of said broadcast
fred goodell here on the rich eisen show
how you doing fred
i'm doing great rich how are you i'm
doing i'm doing very well thank you for
asking um uh let's just jump into it
with both feet here you're
i'm sure you're asked this all the time
uh give me your favorite john madden
story is it the first time you met him
is it during any of the times that he
and al were calling the games is it
before
you'd ever uh had him on on nbc if you'd
known him i'll give you the floor on
that well i i didn't meet john uh until
he came to monday night football and
that that first time we met always
stands out to me because
uh
you know it was classic madden we're at
a steakhouse uh he picked me up at a
hotel we're at a steakhouse and
we're trying to make small talk we're
trying to break the ice and it's really
not it's not really going anywhere and
then finally he grabs the salt and
pepper shaker and he slams down the salt
shake and he said this is john lynch and
he slammed down the pepper shake and he
goes and this is dwight smith who was
opposite john richards of safety back in
the a day of the bucks he said okay now
they're going to run a tight end up the
scene the middle linebacker is going to
carry him up to the safety you know and
then he wanted me to tell him the replay
sequence and what i was going to see and
how it was going to be framed and all
those different things then he then
spent the next
he's just walking tape after tape after
tape and having great conversations
about football and football coverage and
things of that nature so that's the one
that you know always stands out to me
other than
when he got
um you know elected into the hall of
fame
uh
when
we're in the officials locker or the
steelers locker room at ford field he
said he was told he'd be told he'd be
called by 1 pm if he was elected to the
hall of fame
it was now two something in the
afternoon
uh had not received the call but we were
in the bowels of ford field and no one
really had cell service so his agent
kept walking out sandy montagne no calls
and then we hang up with cower and i
just turn on the tv and there you are
and literally as the tv comes on you're
saying and now the class of 2006
and i look at john because i have the
remote and i say what do you want me to
do
and he said just leave it
and you said
troy aikman
harry carson
john madden and when you said john
madden our room exploded and if you saw
the documentary
you know you saw the picture that his
son mike snapped of john and myself and
drew essence off our director
and like you know a man hug
and that that's that's my favorite
moment because i know how much it meant
for him but
there's about a hundred favorite moments
richard freda uh i gotta be honest with
you i'm getting emotional hearing this
because
i didn't know i'm just telling right now
that
i'd literally inform john madden he was
in the hall of fame because i i i i
assumed i assumed the information i was
dispensing that day that the phone call
had already been given to him are you
serious that actually happened
rich here's the crazy part like i
couldn't have cued you up any tighter
queued up well you're a producer
extraordinary click on the tv literally
and you say and now the hall of fame
class of 2006. oh my god and i looked at
john i'm like what do you want me to do
and he said just leave it
and uh you know there you and there you
went
wow
i didn't know that
yeah i mean i gotta tell you and i've
said this before
you know in terms of joyous moments
you're part of in your life obviously
the birth of my daughter will always be
number one
but that one's number two because i know
how much that meant to him and it was
bedroom in that locker
room and that locker room again you're
referring to that was super bowl 40
right um yeah
steelers and and and seahawks
right right
and that was right before al got traded
for oswald the rabbit if i'm not
mistaken right uh 24 hours late or maybe
48 hours later the trade was consummated
i think it was agreed i think it was
agreed to 24 hours later but then 48
hours later uh they made the deal i
remember all of that yeah oh my gosh so
back to fred godelli uh executive
producer of sunday football here on the
rich eisen show back to what you you
were just talking before about your
first time with madden so he's already
signed up espn uh i mean abc had already
gotten him for monday night football and
you're meeting him and he's kicking the
tires on you there with with salt and
pepper shakers is that what you're
saying yeah oh yeah and then we then we
started watching film and we're talking
through all kinds of defenses because
you know back then tampa bay had the
number one defense in football they were
playing that tampa two style of defense
and you know the rams probably had the
best offense and we're going through the
rams offense and we're going through
plays and he's basically telling me okay
now what am i going to see here when
this play happens take me through your
sequence tell me how the shot's framed
am i going to see the safety in the shot
i mean you know very specific things
which you know
i mean i just found you know i mean i
found unbelievably incredible that he
was into that kind of detail
but then once i got to work with him it
wasn't surprised any longer i mean he
just
was a stickler for the details and you
know that's what made him great and
that's what made him you know great for
all of us because he really
he polished us up i mean he really did i
mean we were you know
decent good
and then he made us better well i mean
i've told you this before too fred off
the air i might as well say it here on
the air is you and drew esseko from the
nbc crew um
you never miss a replay when there's uh
when there's a moment on the field or
a penalty or something happened like you
will find the shot the shot is there and
i'm always wondering was that really a
penalty was it not and it's boom it's
right there and that's the phrase that
obviously madden would have used a and
we know how madden telestrates on the
screen and how that changed everything
but how did he change you as a producer
with with the stuff that he was telling
you like is is that what i just
mentioned part of that or you already
had something like that ingrained in you
no i mean i think you know he really
uh in terms of preparation
he really refined you know drew and my
and the whole team's preparation
you know i remember
on game day when the teams would come
out to warm up you know i might step out
of the truck i might
well there wasn't you know i might have
a phone conversation check my phone but
when the teams were on the field for
warm-ups
i mean he was all over and he would say
hey look at this or look at that hey
look what they're doing right here and
all of a sudden we started getting like
really good content for the show
just from warm-ups and maybe some of
that content wasn't visual but it was
preparation and it alerted us to what we
were going to do
and you know just want you know you're
watching coaches tape with the hall of
fame coach you know he's pointing out
things that i would never know you know
on my own
and you know the one other saying that
he had that is sheared in my brain
forever
uh and i think every producer has made
this mistake including myself many times
is that you can't format a live event
and what he meant was hey you might have
all these nice elements and cool stories
coming into the game
but if the game doesn't take you there
then you shouldn't go there
and uh it sounds simple and it really is
simple but it's violated way too much
and like i said i would be you know a
chief violator of that rule much more
before you know i started working with
john
but you know he was all over that and he
really understood tv
you know almost as well as he understood
football i mean he totally got it he
totally understood why it worked and
when it worked and when it did and why
it didn't and all those different things
and
you know and with all that rich
it was all done with the most amount of
fun any human being could ever have
that's what i bet that's what was the
best part about it it didn't feel like
like you were inspired by it you were
invigorated by it you had a great time
doing it it never felt like oh my god
i'm in this intense class and i gotta
get an a it never felt like that i felt
like wow i'm learning this from a hall
of fame coach and i'm having the best
time of my life fred goodell here on the
rich eisen show i've got a few minutes
left with you here fred so i i do want
to go down a little bit of memory lane
you know we we first met way back in the
day in the late 90s at espn i arrived
there in 96 and you started producing
the espy awards in 97
um
another individual who passed away in
recent months norm mcdonald i want to
ask you about
his famed
hosting
and
you're laughing already
it was almost one and done for me
[Laughter]
right i mean
oh yeah what was what was the reaction
when his uh his um
his monologue was was going through
there was that was that something for
you what fred give me something well you
know the monologue i i personally
did not have a problem with the
monologue it was some of the things
afterward
that i had a problem with i mean
obviously there was the oj joke yes uh
and
you know i think it was you know the
reaction shots
that you know the reaction shots at ken
griffey the reaction shots of
charles woodson you know when he's
making these jokes and i quickly found
out
that uh the people that have the least
amount of humor or a sense of humor
about themselves or are professional
athletes yes uh
they don't really have a great sense of
humor about themselves but
uh
yeah so the the monologue i didn't
really have an uh issue with but the
insult directed at elway yeah right you
know that that was you know it wasn't
that was that was feral wasn't that will
ferrell as as uh harry kane
right and i remember you know john walsh
and i oh yeah took that out of the
script i was like hey you can't do this
you know this you know this guy's you
know this guy's a hero you know he's an
american hero he's john elway and you
know of course as you know rich he hands
someone open mike and
you're at their mercy and you know will
farrow went and did what he wanted to do
but yeah i remember after the show uh
your old boss and my old boss steve
bornstein came up to me
congratulated me
if you ever insult our guests again
you'll never do this again is that what
he said he said yeah oh yeah
yeah that's exactly what he said but he
gave you a good job first though because
it was a
good show i got the good job first yes
so the the oj line was in the script
that was scripted the og i mean yeah
walsh and i you know uh
john walsh is the editorial editor of
espn and really the editorial conscience
of espn is rich knows yes uh and you
know we were really going through the
script and we you know no one was being
compared to oj
it was you know it was just a joke about
oj so we didn't feel like it crossed the
line
uh and again i think it was just
exacerbated by the reaction shots of
really ken griffey jr uh maybe even more
so than woodson but
yeah the oj joke was in well i remember
i remember that night big time man i was
in the audience stuart and i had yet to
do the pre-show stuff i think there was
still dan and keith
doing the pre-espy stuff in the uh yeah
it might have been as as dan as i think
keith was referring to like the old
muppet man in the uh you know in the
balcony you know of radio city uh i
remember that night you got any other
sb memory that leaps out to you from
back in the day now that i mean this is
because again when you were doing it i
mean it was it's like what is espn
attempting what are they doing now it's
you know normal now it's part of life
but you and more a man whose name should
be mentioned in this conversation right
now obviously
let's just say this i warmed the chair
for more matt because what maura did
with the sb's
uh was far beyond what i was ever going
to do with them and it was the perfect
show for her and she created you know
the success of the espys are really i
hate to say
it's never really about one person but
it's hard to say it's not all about
maura and what she did in her you know
indomitable will and getting these you
know
superstar athletes and
superstar celebrities
to not only come but to embrace it you
know i mean you know in the beginning it
was hard to get you know a lot of the
athletes to show up it was hard to get
aidless celebrities
you know
morris last show it was it was
star-studded and it was that way for
probably the last ten of moore's shows
so um she was the real you know she was
the real engine behind that uh well two
favorite stories one you know growing up
you know i'm a little bit older than you
and so you know in my in my room when i
was a kid and and in college hung the
farrah fawcett poster
and of course farrah floss is going to
present and now i've got to go over
her lines with her
i don't like i cannot believe this is
happening man i am shooting with four
barrel faucet and i am going over her
lines and it was like you know look yes
you i've met you know pretty much every
athlete there is to me
uh but that was like an unbelievable
moment and then in the same show steven
seagal was presenting an award and he
forgot his talks on his private jet and
went back to l.a so morris says hey
we'll just make you a tux right here at
the mgm grant he goes no i i can't wear
my tux i'm not wearing a tux and he had
on like um get on like a rawhide shirt
with like fringe off the sleeves like he
just come off a movie set where he was
playing you know a native american
and
like you can't go out there like this
and he's like yeah this is what i'm
doing
uh
so i said tomorrow i said okay here's
the deal tell the stage manager just
preset him and i'll tell chip dean
director shoot him from like chest up
but don't let anybody see what he's
wearing
but uh that was all on the same show
ridge
unbelievable fred goodell here in the
rich eisen show before i let you go fred
uh clearly you've been there you've done
that
how does one produce a broadcast where
both teams kneel it 90 times because a
tie gets them both in what what happens
on sunday night football
in las vegas nevada you ready for that
one ninety nine i think the odds of that
happening are infinitesimal
or to non-existent that's just i mean
that that's just not gonna happen i mean
believe it or not believe it or not i
actually used real estate with brandon
staley on the show two days ago to ask
him if the steelers win and the jaguar
somehow pull off the upset of the cults
is he at least aware that both the
raiders
and chargers get in if they tie together
and how how do the mechanics of that
actually work and i apologize to him in
the wind-up of asking him that question
but that's what everybody's talking
about right now like can you imagine
what that would
do with that i know al alan chris would
i had chris on last hour chris said he
would he would eviscerate like he didn't
use that word but i could sense it like
within two seconds if the first snap is
herbert taking a knee you know
it would it would hard to imagine a
bigger black eye right for any
professional league or any any league
even even a pop warner league it's been
two teams uh alternating taking knees
for uh three downs right but i mean
would you would you use what the steady
after a while you get the steadicam out
there you know because there's not going
to be overwhelming game would be covered
from skycam that's
exactly right take it right to the side
hey here comes you know here's the right
foot
of the evening but we did talk with
chris about like what if the game just
because of
the way it works that it does go to
overtime and the first team kicks the
field goal the next team kicks a field
goal and there's a minute and a half to
go like do you
like chris even said like one guy like
one team takes a knee because a tie gets
them in and if the other team fires off
a timeout then you know they're not
they're not in
you know like that that could act that
could happen right yeah you could almost
understand that at that point right you
know if you're now in your you know 69th
minute of football right
and all you have to do is tie this game
to get in
you can understand that and
i could probably support that you know
what i mean right uh it's so wild yeah
i'd be fine with that rich if that
happened i'd be totally fine with that
and that means we probably had a great
rating because we're in overtime that's
right
way to go fred thanks for the time man
happy new year to you and yours i really
appreciate it you thank you always love
it take care thanks brother that's fred
goodell right here at
snf
nbc on twitter to follow him
at snf on nbc to follow the game which
by the way is coming your way on nbc and
peacock this sunday night yes herbert
and derek carr they're not even going to
wear knee pads they're not taking these
folks
no helmets just walk out just like that
just walk out
shake hands kneel
yeah right sunday 7 eastern nbc and
peacock hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here